so you guys sent me by our suite at
comic-con over the summer and Linda one
of the things that you had said was that
you never forget the first thing that
really scared you so I'm curious whether
it's a legend like fly your own up where
a scary movie do you all remember the
very first thing that scared you as a
kid I used to I used to hear that there
was a there was a man that I don't that
was a very hairy man and I remember I
was probably like 6 years old I went
into my bed and I found the feet of
these men I run out of my bed in ever
since I don't I cannot ever sleep with
my feet outside the sheets uh as a child
I was frightened by law you don't know
the story of her that was the first
thing because everyone in our community
man let me everyone believes in her yeah
so you don't just hear it from your
family you hear from your friends from
your cousins of everyone around
everyone's talking about her this is
very frightening and to be a part of the
film's amazing I had a closet door in my
bedroom growing up and it kind of had
this trick to it
that it wouldn't close properly you had
to like kind of Jimmy yet so like you
would always draw it open just like a
couple inches
it was so unnerving and I was literally
terrified I would always try and muster
the strength to like to like close but
sometimes I just leave it open because I
was too terrified to get out of bed too
close but I think about that often I was
painting about itself I always wanted me
like my brother my sister like I wanted
to be like near people and I came from a
big family so that wasn't hard but I
remember that my brother would just
scare me at every turn you know such a
chicken you just jump out of everywhere
and scare me and in the middle of the
night like bang on the door and yeah oh
yeah that's gonna keep you up for a
while I imagine um I wanted to ask you
early conversations with James here
because one of the interesting things
that I found with the movie now that
I've actually seen it is you've got your
own style here but I see you tapping
into a lot of the things that I know and
love from let's say the conjuring like
one of those opening shots where you're
tracking through the house so what was
your initial conversations with him like
and did he give you any pointers first
of all so many pointers I you know
honestly James I've been a huge fan of
James Wong and to work with them was
just incredible and you know he's such a
big supporter of such great Ally and
since just like a lover of not just
horror movies but like lover of movies
um interesting the end you know the the
one shot you know part of the idea was
you know to kind of a nod to the
conjuring universe you know not saying
that this falls into the conjuring
universe if it did that Vyasa would be
something that audiences could discover
and so we are talking about father Perez
right now uh he's on the IMDB page yeah
use on the InP exactly it's something to
discover whoa is it the same father
Perez I don't know you know it's a good
question audiences need to go to the
theater and you know answer that
question themselves but you know that
was definitely a nod and you know it's
actually funny because the idea of that
one shot it it's definitely a James Wan
trademark the idea came from Walt Hamada
who is it was one of the executives on
this and you know now he's running you
know DC films he is a very smart guy he
really was you know masterminded this
whole project from the beginning and it
was his idea and you know one of the
great things about it that what he said
and I think it's three reason James puts
it in his movies is when you're spending
that much time in a scary movie in one
location it's really important to orient
people with the geography and it's funny
because you even see that technique in
like video games sometimes or they'll do
like a fly through the level or
something that kind of orient to you
about like where everything's laid out
because geography is so important I
think engaging everyone
and you know what swear is you know it's
like you're laying out the chessboard
and this is like these are all the
things we're gonna be messing with you
know let's see what happens okay I want
to embarrass you a little bit because
big deal this guy right here is
directing the third countering movie
we're gonna be hearing your name for
quite a while right yeah so I was
curious for the three of you can you
tell me one thing that Michael did as a
director here that you've never
experienced before that maybe brought
something out of you that you didn't
expect enthusiasm that I think you know
he's a true leader but his enthusiasm is
so contagious you cannot help but want
to be a part of it by far I think he's
one of the most collaborative people you
know there there were a lot of us and a
lot of opinions and a lot of like true
life stories that people had about lyre
and like the idea that he would
incorporate people's ideas and be so
open to it especially with your first
film where people are so nervous and
just you know people can be rigid
because of that he had none of that ya
know that he loves he really cares about
this movie that was the best thanks
another shout out I want to give right
now because again my mind goes back to
the conjuring and with Joe Bashara
playing Bathsheba and that is I feel
like the unsung hero this movie is gonna
wind up being it the actor who played
liar onna so can you guys tell me a
little bit about working with her she's
dead
fantastic I remember when you showed me
a picture of Em's like she's so
beautiful how is actually gonna be this
and and that she could not have been a
more perfect partner for all of us she
was such a good sport cuz to be in that
makeup and it took a long time to get
into that makeup it was very unforgiving
and she would stay in it she had to be
wet a lot of the time she's a beautiful
sense of humor she's a great actress and
we're actually gonna see her you know I
don't want to spoil anything but you
actually could just see her go through
so much and if it weren't for her and
the way that she handled us and the way
that she handled the children and the
way that we were able to play against a
real person and not something that was
computer-generated
would have been a completely different
experiment adversity yeah - she was okay
[Music]